when it first popped on the scene
cryptocurrency was considered a risky
alternative investment and many say that
hasn't changed something that has its
value six years ago on this very day you
could buy a single bitcoin for around
244
dollars but today it is over 55 000
not everyone buys bitcoin but many are
engaged in the high stakes effort to
create them through a mind-bending
process of electronic mining
and that's where virtual currency may
create real world concerns for the
environment cbs news meteorologist and
climate specialist jeff beradelli has
the story
good morning the opportunity to make big
money is now attracting huge investments
to industrial scale bitcoin mining with
thousands of supercomputer mining
machines and enormous energy demand
so much energy that some companies are
using power plants to fuel their
operations
but critics fear that may have
significant environmental consequences
it's stunning you could just be driving
along the highway and see a magnificent
waterfall it's it's spectacular here
yvonne taylor's family has lived along
the shores of seneca lake for seven
generations an idyllic spot nestled in
new york's picturesque finger lakes
region we've got waterfalls gorges water
to swim in fresh water to drink an
abundance of agriculture wine tourism
it's a piece of heaven right here but
now she says her piece of heaven is
threatened taylor is a leader of seneca
lake guardian an environmental watchdog
engaged in a battle over this once
shuttered power plant the plant named
greenwich generation lay dormant for
more than five years it was converted
from coal to natural gas and fired back
up in 2017 by a private investment firm
with the intent to supply power to the
grid now in addition to supplying power
the company has an industrial scale
bitcoin mining business on the property
an operation that's been growing
recently the number of mining machines
has doubled from around seven thousand
to over fifteen thousand according to an
sec filing by greenwich generation in
march the plant powered 19 megawatts of
mining capacity the document shows they
expect that to more than quadruple by
the end of 2022
now producing power requires millions of
gallons of water to be drawn from the
lake to help cool the process that water
is then permitted to be sent back into
seneca lake measurably warmer than it
was when it came in and some residents
worry the potentially warmer water may
disturb the balance of the ecosystem i
feel like we are stewards of the land
our roots run deep here tina hazlitt's
family has owned this farm on seneca
lake since 1852 there's no evidence the
warm water outflow is causing
environmental damage now but she fears
for the future what greenwich is doing
threatens our lake it threatens our
water and for me that threatens
my grandchildren but greenwich disagrees
in a series of emails with cbs news a
greenwich spokesperson says the town has
approved of the company's site plan
greenwich is in full compliance with all
of its permits and there's no evidence
of environmental harm but hazlitt says
given greenwich's plan to grow their
bitcoin business more study is crucial
we need to throw up the red flags and
say slow down let's investigate this
let's look into
what could really
happen to our water happen to our air
as a result of the growth of bitcoin
mining
but why does bitcoin mining require so
much energy that it pays to own a power
plant because every bitcoin transaction
activates thousands of super computing
mining machines all competing against
each other to solve puzzling
mathematical problems each vying to be
the first to validate that transaction
and in return win new bitcoin more
machines and cheaper power means more
profit so for power plants not operating
at full capacity mining can be an
attractive new revenue stream but the
impacts aren't isolated to the finger
lakes region emissions from the burning
of natural gas contribute to climate
change and advocates are concerned the
floodgates are about to open to open
back up shuttered power plants across
the nation
outside of the state of new york there
are many many more of these plants
hundreds we met former cornell
university professor and natural gas
expert tony ingrafia just a finger lake
away
surrounded by the sounds of the
university's famous clock tower there
are two other plants that are now
targeted in new york state to quickly
open up he says using power plants to
mine bitcoin raises an ethical concern
because of emissions of carbon dioxide
and methane leakage which is common
along the supply chain leading to the
plant methane is over the short term 100
times more potent than co2 the un says
the best lever we have to meet our paris
goals is to reduce methane emissions now
firing up bitcoin
mining
across the country for private
enterprise without regard to social good
is a really bad thing to be doing we're
at the very very leading edge of this
phenomenon of cryptocurrency mining by
burning natural gas it's going to get
worse it's a trend that is ramping up
bitcoin miners are making deals to
utilize or even purchase power plants in
western new york montana and
pennsylvania just to name a few
and critics say the bitcoin industry's
carbon emissions are already immense
larger than the total emissions of
sweden and switzerland combined in fact
a recent study found that bitcoin mining
alone has the potential to catapult us
past the warming targets set by the
paris agreement if you look at all the
energy consumption of google amazon
facebook combined this is more energy
than all of them anna kellis is talking
about bitcoin mining she's a new york
state assembly member who says the
industry used to be lucrative for the
little guy now it's tougher to compete
so mining bitcoin has become an economy
of scale yes absolutely you need to have
as many computers as possible and you
need those computers online every single
second of every single day she worries
using power plants for industrial scale
mining will cause an escalation of
emissions that may undermine new york's
ambitious climate goals
so she's proposing a moratorium on this
type of operation if they can work their
way through all the regulations in new
york state which has some of the highest
regulations in the country it really
sets a precedent
together kellis and concerned residents
like ivan taylor we are anytown usa and
this could happen in any community are
hoping to get ahead of this burgeoning
bitcoin phenomenon before they fear it
gets out of control we have to nip this
in the bud or else everything else we're
doing to fight climate change will be
undermined
greenwich told cbs news they have
purchased carbon credits to offset their
co2 emissions from the plant now their
five-year air permit is up for renewal
now in an august letter to new york's
department of environmental conservation
greenwich said that it is in compliance
with new york's greenhouse gas emissions
targets established by the new climate
law
new york's dec says greenwich's
application has not yet demonstrated
compliance with those requirements dec
has not made a final determination on
the permit public hearings are planned
and the dec is accepting public comments
on the renewal through october 22nd and
they've asked for more information from
greenwich as for cryptocurrencies carbon
footprint there may be a way to
significantly reduce emissions the
second largest cryptocurrency ethereum
just announced it's changing the way
that they verify transactions they say
this will reduce emissions by over 99
a lot to think about jeff thank you very
much